Gav:
Today, we're near Uvalde.
I'm about to fire a tank.
Fire!
- Oh!
- Whoa!
Gav: That was intense.
Dan: It blew me away.
It's outpacing
that shockwave.
Dan: Oh, there's a shockwave.
You can see the shockwave.
Gav: I think that's
some of the coolest footage
I've ever seen.
What is this?
It's my baby. Fire!
It's an absolute war zone.
( exhaling )
Well, that was, honestly,
some of the most insane
high-speed footage I've seen.
I think my brain's just
about recovered
from the shockwaves of that.
- It was loud.
The D20 was loud.
Three, two, one, fire!
Did you hear that?
That was one of my most fun
days I think, actually.
- Yeah?
- Firing a tank is awesome.
When I was a kid
I always wanted to know
what it'd be like
to be in a tank.
So we're inside
the Sherman right now.
It's pretty cramped.
It would have
five people usually.
You got the driver
and the co-driver.
You have a commander,
the gunner's seat,
and you'd also have a loader
whose only job
is to load the gun.
This here's the breech,
which is where you'd
load the ammunition in.
So you have to punch it in
with your fist
and quickly remove your fist,
'cause this part
will come across and lock in
and then you can fire it.
I can't imagine, especially
with five people in here,
what the change
in pressure must be like
when this thing's
getting hit or shooting.
Actually being
inside the tank,
you get much less of an effect
when you're firing it.
It doesn't feel as beefy.
Because you're outside,
you have all that pressure.
Whereas inside,
you don't really,
'cause you got that
breech protecting you,
and you got steel
all around you.
You know,
people overuse the word,
- but it's awesome.
- Yeah.
- It's very cool.
But how do you drive it?
- Yeah.
- There's no wind screen.
- That's fair.
Is there a steering wheel?
Like, what's going on?
I actually would--
I have no idea.
What even are the controls?
Pedals, buttons, levers?
- Yeah.
- I just assumed it was
a thumbstick
- kind of controller.
- Of course you did.
So we took
the opportunity
to learn
how to drive a tank.
I'm up in the tower.
Okay, I'll try not to crash
or do anything too rash.
Yeah, try not
to bend the thing.
All right,
so to start it up,
just click it.
Down, yep.
Very satisfying.
We're gonna
be heading toward...
Yeah.
( man laughs )
Perfect.
A little shopping--
No. Okay.
Is it fun to drive?
It's pretty cool.
- You just have
these two levers.
- Think I could drive it.
- I think you could do it.
- Yeah?
I think that even though
you can't even drive a car,
I think you could
drive a tank.
- Don't have a driver's license.
- I think it's easier.
Well, now we all know
how to drive a Sherman tank
- in an emergency.
- Or a zombie apocalypse.
Or a zombie apocalypse.
Next up, to help us learn more
about how a tank works,
we have an ammunition
technician.
- Dan.
- Hello.
- Thanks for coming on.
- My pleasure.
What could you tell us
about the tanks
that we were in?
Well, the one we just drove,
that was a jumbo.
There was only 250
of them ever made.
And you run us through
what actually occurs
in the tank when it fires?
I can.
This is the projectile
that was fired
by the tank itself.
It's about 15
and a half pounds.
Can't really relate to that.
- It's over a stone.
- Yeah, it's the equivalent
of three whole bags of flour.
What would you rather
get hit by?
This or three bags
of flour?
Well, I mean,
probably this,
but at that
sort of speed,
either one would
probably do some damage.
That would just
be a lot more dusty.
- Yeah.
- Poof!
So what happens is,
if I lay it down
on the side here,
imagine here we've got
the cartridge case.
What happens
when you fire the tank
when I was pulling
that little string,
a firing pin was impinging
onto the primer
and that was igniting
the propellant
inside the cartridge case.
That propellant
is hitting the base
of the projectile here.
You see this part here?
This is called a driving band.
This is copper.
- So this is softer.
- This is softer.
So if you look down
the barrel of the gun,
you'll see the rifling
like twisting grooves.
And because this
is slightly wider
than the projectile itself,
the copper engages
in the rifling
of the barrel.
And that then imparts a spin
on the projectile.
So this little strip
is the reason
it's coming out like this.
- Yeah. And I'll show you
what I mean.
- Okay.
This is one
that we've previously fired.
- Obviously--
- Can you guess
which has been fired?
Yeah, we dug this
out of the ground
and you can actually see these
individual grooves here
are the copper that have gone
through the rifling there.
This engages in the teeth
of the barrel
and then causes the projectile
to spin when it comes out.
Every ten inches
it travels,
it's done
a complete rotation.
So to clearly illustrate
what I'm talking about
we can just see
the footage.
This is my favorite shot.
Gav: So almost as it travels
the length of itself,
it's coming round
on a full rotation.
- Dan: Yeah.
- Gav: So if it wasn't spinning,
that would just be tumbling
through the air.
And you can definitely see
the rotation from the rifling.
Dan: It's like
an American football.
When you throw one,
you spin it
- and it stabilizes in flight.
- Yeah.
So, obviously,
1,700 feet per second
- is faster than
the speed of sound.
- Yeah.
Which is why we've got these
bow waves you can see
in the air.
We actually got very lucky
with the fact that this is,
you know, it's a gradient
from blue to a darker color.
You can see it very clearly
'cause you got two colors
coming together.
Which I've never seen before
with, like,
naked eye, obviously.
That's very cool.
Holding it,
and it's so dense.
It's like, wow,
that is seriously damaging.
That one was 15 pounds,
but the one we fired
from the 152 mil
D20. Hold this.
- There you go.
- Yeah.
That's a lot heavier.
It's about half
your weight I think.
This shell actually
comes out really fast
even though the way
it defeats armor
is very different.
This used the power and speed
to penetrate the armor.
Whereas this
has an explosive
charge in it,
which is what damages it.
It used a completely
different method
to penetrate the tanks.
And we actually found
some of the remnants.
We did.
We dug this out
of the earth bank
in the back.
- So this is our one.
- Yeah.
Just crumpled.
The force that has
to do that is mental.
Well, thank you very much,
Dan, for teaching me
- a lot about how tanks work.
- My pleasure.
Well, hopefully you enjoyed
that episode. I did.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys over here,
and make sure you check out
other episodes
of "Planet Slow Mo".
- What?
- Nothing.